does no one think this is fishy i do
wow hey man you can't do that now can i
ask you this more [ __ ] should be able to
take whatever he wants yes because
should come it's used to the guilt you
look like [ __ ] chung lee
from bloodsport just trapped from here
to here
[ __ ] like this but [ __ ] you
i'm like sir have you been in the sun
you got quite a suntan
or it looks like a sunburn and i've seen
a number of people like that
with the hot dogs your tomato redstone
i'm talking about hot that's
i keep forgetting about that it's called
hot dog skin hot dogs
you look like a human hot dog you're
doing trt and you're way bigger what's
going on with your traps and you're
you're 43.
i don't know 63 like 35 35.
[ __ ] you you're not 35 with a flat top
he's way older than 35. i think he's
more than 35
100 please let's call a [ __ ] zebra
zebra
i've become or let's call a plum a plum
because every time i see somebody's on
trt
they're plum purple like he could
guzzle [ __ ] horse semen yeah and he
would still get punched in the face yes
and this is my thing ready go ahead mean
chuckle delegate on arguing about this
last night at dinner here's one for you
name drop sorry
what do you got i'll tell you it was
embarrassing last night we had this
business dinner chuck was there heidi
his wife was there who's
amazing and you know it's that no boot
why can't eat the rice on this keto diet
yeah
and they're ordering all this food i'm
like oh that's cool and then
like half an hour chuck goes what are
you on a [ __ ] diet or something
yeah chuck my dough he's just your best
melees it gets you
a [ __ ] diet or something stupid yeah
why were you trying to fight it too if i
was on it no why
why the [ __ ] would you do it i was like
straight up
looks and tv god damn it did i just say
that to chuck liddell
not making this up not making this up
as i'm saying that young kid probably
first night on the gig
big bottle of ice water oh my god all
over chocolate
he goes like he goes that kid goes like
this
and then he doesn't realize it's
chuckling he looks up he goes
oh god you and you know you think chuck
like that's all good man
no he gave him the iceman look like he
was fighting tito ortiz the kid was all
hey you [ __ ] jeff jeff
and the manager get a [ __ ] towel
jar jaw the kid must have been 18. oh
man i could not stop
laughing so i was laughing because
the attention was on me my stupid
[ __ ] diet
then the kids like hey how's it going no
ice water all over the ice man
i smarter on the iceman holy [ __ ] and
chuck wasn't like ah that's all right
chuck just gave him the ice
man stare he's he's just going like this
and he goes come on man
they looked at him and then stood up and
he was like
you pat him was like it's all good it's
all good sat down the kid was literally
like
yeah it's chocolate down yeah that's
where she's walking away hey
you're fired yeah he was laughing you're
fired
oh man jesus christ water
water hey hey cool down the only thing
would make that better if he'd gone
you got to cool down chuck all right
iceland
hey iceman yeah yeah how are you
at desert island oh oh that's counting
this only our 300 show that's my agency
that's my agency i can't answer it
can't answer it they're telling me
they're telling me i got a jennifer
garner movie to tell me if i can
if i can you know push the victory and
put it somewhere else
as much as you can that's amazing
that would be your phone down here we've
only done 200 shows he's been in show
business for 20 years
for you it can really [ __ ] you up when i
did letterman in 1999 i had to go do
stand up and they wanted me to do
they have a letterman i did they wanted
i didn't know that b yeah that's it
that's a that's a really cool it's epic
and and
johnny carson too no uh
i think it was bonnie franklin remember
bonnie franklin from one day at a time
oh i don't come on that
dad but from a medical standpoint from a
medical standpoint
when you explode into somebody else and
you go like that
do that your your bung hole pushes out
right when your bung hole pushes out a
little ass juice
this is science a little ass juice kind
of has to come out a little bit
so you're right i would say defensive
because when you're this is what i want
to know
i had a girl i got done with jiu jitsu
this [ __ ] had my legs pinned back like
she had you
changed my diaper
yeah she had changed my diaper i dude i
got done
i thought brian i was like i just got
assaulted bro i could never talk to this
girl again
i felt like she took my man she was
already asked for wait
i didn't ask for it you went just done
with jiu jitsu or you showered no i just
got done jiu jitsu no shower
meet up with this one i was single then
she's on me like donkey kong
boom grabs my big ass legs pins them
back i'm like oh
[ __ ] i'm not that flexible i'm not like
eddie bravo or rogan
some of them like the way the dick
tastes in there she peels the peach
thumb man yeah i broke my finger i'm a
fighter it was a voiceover
and somebody said something to me about
my jeans and i go well the thing is i'm
sponsored by stud
uh it's a it's an organization and uh
i'm a very good looking guy and a dude
looks at me and he goes duh
yes because one time bert kreischer and
i went
wow one two bears you'll love this
brian i i was designing shirts for our
east coast tour and we're going to new
york
okay i gotta say out on this beach so i
have this cool
new york graphic and it's the new york
knick colors
okay new york knicks okay okay new york
i show brian
we have a boston one he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] we got philly and he goes
that new york one i mean the design's
cool but those are the denver broncos
colors man
and he was dead serious and i went oh no
and he goes
i went new york knicks doesn't ring your
belly why don't you oh [ __ ]
it didn't all my friends were drogon
rogan and him now best friends you and
him best friends
[ __ ] jeremy piven and him best
friends all my friends literally no
longer
speak towards me it's incredible you're
the connector you're the connector i'm
the apex
i get [ __ ] boxed out that's it that's
a that's amazing
just so we can see how many times have i
worn these i've literally
never washed them i've never washed them
and and is there any rip in my
in my yeah these were your in your
package sits snug in them no
i'm packing my my guy i know that's what
i'm saying i'm packing heat you're
packing heat and
you have lots of room dude right you
want to jump some current events
i mean you know i just feel like what
what time is it i don't know man this
stupid watch i'm wearing doesn't tell
time very well well it doesn't look that
great
well why don't you that girl goes like
this hey cool kid check this out boom
kid's dead that's my kid
we're gonna have to go ahead and shoot
that thing in the [ __ ] gorilla face
did you did you watch the video
no i didn't i can't watch you die i just
i just saw him playing with the kid
he's protecting him but mom sounded very
calm it was weird
see the mom should go to jail for a
little bit because because to me
i don't give a [ __ ] what you got going
on i don't care if the rhino's over
there [ __ ] a tiger you've never seen
something like that before
if your kid's around the gorilla exhibit
and he can get in that's weird
you're a [ __ ] parent how do the kids
fall into the gorilla exhibit
she was like balls deep in the in the
monkeys next door and the kid's like
checking the gorilla
goods falls in giant grill's like oh
this is cool
yeah why would you not have your eyes on
your kid all the time oh annual the
grill just happened to be
they're saving his uh semen because they
want him to procreate with all these
gorillas because
you know the silverbacks of his nature
yeah are hard to come by
so he's in this [ __ ] program where
they're gonna build back up the gorillas
not anymore damn it's cause of the mom
and by the way silverback gorillas take
a long time to get
to be silver she's seen this thing you
should have seen this 600 pound
animal yes but he was protecting the kid
but again at first i was like [ __ ] that
man they should have killed the gorilla
it's so jacked up and then rogan goes
yeah
but let's say tiger fell in there what
would you do yeah i'm going to take that
bazooka and blow that thing out of the
water unfortunately to figure it out
um hey man you're looking burly as m as
a
mofo then you're a new i don't think i
have a kenny
fighter burley's a good word burley is
burley's at work he's like
you say burly's like you see a big bear
like
yeah you're a big you're a big muscular
bear you're a burly guy
well i'm not here he barely would be
hairy like me saying
you look no really doesn't mean harry
really no well i hear burly i think
i i think harry actually i know what you
mean like burly like a big rough
like afghani or cha-cha chechen
yeah just a big you know hairy chest
yeah just kind of
big and barrel-chested
where's your um make no mistake
you you burly you burly boy
boys yeah brilliant i [ __ ] up because
where i get my hair cut
it's only twenty dollars it's 18. and i
i know what you did
you overtipped the first time not even
over tipped it's 18. you know they gave
me a great haircut
i like these guys i was taking pictures
blah blah blah
they listen to the show well now i'm
screwed they listen to the show
and uh there's eighteen dollars like
such a good deal that's a good deal
that's a very good deal yes and you know
me i
i get my haircut at least once a week so
i'm like [ __ ] man so i go in there
i'm like yeah what's sixty dollars i'm
doing well in life you're sixty dollars
damn it
no it's exactly the amount of [ __ ] i do
went back the next week
got my haircut he's like ah thanks man
but i could tell when i walked in like
oh shop here here i'm like
everyone's anxious freak cutting my hair
that's cool sit down they want that
sixty dollars again
when you when you tip 200 percent well
you know so i was like
okay with the because it's a cash only i
go to the atm i'm like oh
sure gotta take out 60 again that's
switchbar yeah that kind of
i'm assuming he's gay yeah he's gay but
of course yeah
he's a he's again he's not like aggro i
agree yeah i agree better not real aggro
they really they don't want to talk
about sports he's also not attracted to
me so it's all it's always like he's
like hey how are you
whatever the case is honeydecking as
soon as you fall asleep
dick well that's how that's how men are
uh as soon as you fall asleep
we have a bunch of tigers in the tall
grass he and he's just a
skinny feminine type not tall grass make
me
soon he's rubbing
[Laughter]
why am i dreaming try this new palm too
much drank great wine and i slept
like a baby sometimes you need that
it was fantastic there's nothing like
sleeping really well and then i yoga out
stretch it out open my shoulders post a
picture this morning on instagram of
me sitting there with coffee right
before a live show i think it was the
sold out gramsci theater and you're
doing yoga behind me that's right shot
that's a great shot hey good dude
[Applause]
your hair is extra funky what am i
dreaming about i'm not dreaming about a
popsicle
on a hot day
[Applause]
why are we why are we 10 years old so i
don't know why are we telling you [ __ ]
we're having a nice conversation right
here
i think you got to get him out of there
but the man's got a body on him
a white anaconda albino
he's got a big old angry doll dick and
he's like a giant
albino pterodactyl yeah it's big and
mean
and mean it's mean it doesn't have wings
though and a sharp beak though let's get
that clear so
it's kind of sharp sharp beak it's gotta
refer to pieces now pterodactyls some
guys have a giant doorknob head
yeah yeah they kind of have those morgan
freeman noses on the end of their dick
my roommate in high school had the
biggest
dick of all time black black gentlemen
african-american gentleman
of course and his uh dick i saw it hard
one time
because he was playing around with a
friend of mine this girl and he walked
out and i went holy mother of god and it
had a
bend to it it's so big bro it didn't
stand straight up
the skin yeah the humidity this bad boy
this bad boy had a nice
beautiful chiquita banana arc but
pointing down
his dick pointed down you know how a
ruler when you like
uh the tape measure when you keep going
so far just bends a little correct
i've been there the banks and so the
problem is when you do that you create
your own tribe
so when you say the banks and
corporations when you say that when you
categorize
anybody look at how the the republicans
or conservatives categorize people who
are gun control advocates
they call them bleeding heart liberals
they call they categorize them
so what you do when you do that is you
take a human being in all his complexity
all his emotional complexity
and you you reduce him to down to two
words and those two words are always
derogatory you are labeling
and we keep doing that as human beings
my tribe over here
and instead of me trying to be a
missionary and change your mind
change your mind or at least get to you
emotionally and see where i'm coming
from
the first thing we do is go oh i'm
religious i mean i'm an atheist you're
religious
you believe in fairy tales you're a
dumbass now tell the people to send in
9.99
because they would like tone like like
you sound like on something evangelistic
because they asked for 999.99
and 9.99 999 9.99
joined the brian cowan cult it's less
limited thousand dollars
limited is that a thousand dollars now i
got to get the [ __ ] out of here now i
got to go
i got to go i got fan questions okay fan
question i got to get the [ __ ] out of
here
holy [ __ ] now that was good that was
good
do you notice that your partner yeah
your ace boom [ __ ] he's [ __ ] texting
while you're dropping knowledge like he
could give up everything
he's like time he's like every time and
he's searching for text and then he's
like you know going into
searching do you know everything
responding he has a weird thing because
every time i do drop knowledge he's
[ __ ] eyes crossed no it just depends
if if it's one i know or we talked about
before then yeah because you're gonna go
off on it yeah yeah
and yeah because i know the kid you know
that red robin bird that comes around
he's like whoa
fries how are they yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ]
dude in a big red robin outfit well
we're there with my dad
our best friend anthony turner at the
time and then my brother it's the four
of us
and he kept coming around and you know
they're older me so i always want to
impress him i'm like
i'm like if he comes around here and
watch this and you know he's like whoa
hey kids and i just i clocked my hand
back go
literally slap this dude why is that
funny to me as hard as i can
i'm like nine and he's like wow hey
everybody i'm like
how's it going mr red robin and then
he's like look at my brother like yeah
hey how's the fries i'm like
he turns back at me i'm like yeah
and he goes oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you walks back to the break room
and my dad i thought everyone's dying
laughing my dad is
yeah oh yes that's so mad my dad goes
you know how embarrassing that is for
that guy you don't think he's already
embarrassed working that [ __ ] job
and he gets the manager over there he
goes
where's the where's that guy at and he
was what happened is my slunts my son
slapped the [ __ ] out of your the guy is
it a kid and he goes
no it's a grown man he goes well where's
he at he goes you're gonna [ __ ]
apologize
all right then your dad's awesome he's
like you're gonna apologize grabs me
like punks me by my arm
we go in the break room with some
[ __ ] every bit of 45
fat dude balding he's like i think it
was like the
final straw for me just goes can't do
this [ __ ] anymore
and he's like talking with the manager
you know and my dad's like hey man
the the kid who hit you it's my son i i
apologize i teach him better than this
my dad like put santa like jesus i don't
blame your dad yeah and then i'm like
sorry slapped you man he's all that's
all good
i'm incredible but
i don't think that she ever
ever trimmed ever trimmed once in her
life
i don't think she had that 70s bush oh
no it was more than that it was like
uh a bear a bear's paw did people still
do that
it was the credit no but this girl still
do that she went down her legs
this went down her legs dude i was like
she was gorgeous and i was like
how are you gonna have that she i she
could see my face and she goes i'm an
earth mother
an earth mother hmm all right well
that's a beard that's a beard down there
okay the goat starts to flip out i i
have
my whole day planned i got this girl i'm
gonna take on a hike i [ __ ] can't
wait she's hot as [ __ ] yeah
hot as [ __ ] dumb she was such a dumb
dumb
but she loved me she'd be like you have
such guts because she thought she loved
she's like acting she was like just the
way you guys like you have such guts
because i would tell her stories and
she's like you're just you're just going
for it you're going for it i was like
i am look at this swallow this pool
boycott that's my dick here you go
yeah it's like we talked about in rogan
if you haven't seen it
what we're referring to is uh mr hands
the guy likes to [ __ ] horses
and then die by getting [ __ ] by a
horse because the horse went balls deep
and ripped his innards
ripped his innards but this look it up
you'll find it online if you google mr
hannah's video that'll hurt you
dude but you should see it like the guy
just first of all he's
white as a ghost and they're in the
night in this barn you can see this guy
like a [ __ ] silver surfer
and he's just he's like like the silver
person he's like this and he's like yeah
get in there go go
and there's a three-man job so he likes
having his ass that puts
up on hay and then this fat
dick from another planet i'm telling you
i this isn't doing it justice b
jesus i'm holding my hands up like that
michael jordan poster because dick's
like that
okay like this this thing and the guy's
guiding it in there like
[ __ ] you know like uh like you know
what i thought about
when you said that he's like this and he
just goes
and then the horse goes yeah
and
yeah he was like oh god yeah and then
the horse
is like pulls out and it's just like
oh blood everywhere no come
like one of the biggest cinnabons you've
ever seen just
icing icing icing icing icing
stop the icing stop the icing and then
the horse like
then the horse like pulls back like this
killer man
oh no because the guy at first was like
oh ah
killed him killed him went right up into
his body literally
yeah you don't do that can humans do
that to girls like
can a girl die no but i swear to god i
would like mandingo will it kill him no
but i do know that they that that
that people have used i know in certain
militaries
in the military certain certain military
uh dictatorships in
latin america used to use dogs to [ __ ]
guys and girls um dogs dicks what was
the biggest dog
they'd use giant schnauzers for real and
they would giant [ __ ] yeah that's the
humiliation
it's the humiliation but there's not
killing actually have you ever seen a
dog's fully erect penis it's
bulbous bring it up on the internet
they're actually way longer than you
think
i'm not doing that you know it's like
this no that's what it that's what it
looks like you're talking about the red
rocks when they enter you
when they enter the dog it could there's
much more that goes in yeah it's like
the alien
tongue and aliens yeah like yellow head
comes out people have used animals to
torture people especially having sex
with them yeah well if you want to do it
use this
horse and have it rip through your
[ __ ] into your throat
there's always those people out there
that come up with [ __ ] but so this
guy has been doing it forever
but he didn't die right away because he
works for boeing so he was like yo man
i can't go to the emergency room saying
i was [ __ ] horses and his dick went
through the top of my throat
i gotta you know i gotta wear this off
and they're like you might have internal
bleeding
and so he's like no i'm just gonna stay
at home he's not doing well feeling like
[ __ ]
so his friend drops him off at the
emergency room because he worked for a
bone he's like i can't get in trouble
he dies waiting to be seen oh no
oh no mr hands rest in peace that's
pretty awful